what's your strategy to win big brother  canada okay to be honest with you i feel  like the real strategy is to not have a  strategy because you never know what  you're gonna get into when you hop up in  that house so i would say  for the most part i just want to  maintain a positive mindset a strong  mindset and i always want to put  god  myself and erisa cox first in anything  that i do  i love ferisa cox and she's always  bringing the afro energy and i hope that  you know we get in a little bit of a in  a fromance something new this year not a  showmance not a flirt dance but a  fromance  so the types of people that i will not  get along with are people that like to  run their mouths like 24 7.  i don't get along with people like that  i don't like people who take my words  and you know  twist them and manipulate them it's not  for me i don't get along with people  like that in the outside world then you  better believe i won't get along with  people like that in the bb can 10 house